la muerte de decenas de emigrantes esta
semana en el canal de la mancha tensa
nuevamente en las relaciones entre
francia y reino unido- desde croacia el
presidente francés pidió fortalecer la
cooperación entre países vecinos
junto a ministros durante avión donde se
hará una serie de reuniones con el
ministro del interior en las próximas
horas y días para prevenir mejor las
llegadas a suelo francés desde el sur
así como las rutas norte y este inglés y
para involucrar mejor a los británicos
en la prevención de esas afluencia
mediante el desmantelamiento de las
redes de contrabandistas
el naufragio de un barco inflable que
zarpó desde cale en el norte de francia
con dirección al reino unido y que
provocó varias muertes indigno a la
población
[Música]
cuando vemos a todas esas personas
durmiendo en las calles no es lógico
dejar que esto siga pasando
desgraciadamente los que siguen llegando
deberían dejar de venir francia debe
hacer algo
y si la fiscal cuyos luego de que
londres asegurará que los esfuerzos de
parís para patrullar sus playas fueron
inadecuados la ministra del interior
británica ofreció patrullajes conjuntos
para evitar que los viajes organicen
y me ofrecí a trabajar con francia para
enviar más oficiales al terreno y hacer
lo que sea necesario para asegurar la
zona para que las personas vulnerables
no arriesguen su vida subiendo
embarcaciones en mal estado este jueves
un grupo de migrantes llegó al puerto
inglés de dover donde fueron
transportados a centros temporales el
número de personas que cruce el canal de
la mancha ha aumentado en los últimos
meses luego de que los dos gobiernos
tomaran medidas más drásticas contra
otras formas de emigración ilegal